[Música]
[Aplausos]
se pueden imaginar la cara
de esa persona que vio por primera vez
la rueda
o no mejor aún
vámonos
cien mil años antes de cristo
bueno eso fue la invitación que le hice
a mi sexto básico ese día
ustedes alumnos y alumnas saben cuánto
se demoraba
un hombre en adquirir su alimento
y ahí de atrás del escenario
y de todo el salón para levantar la mano
cuartito eduardito eduardito es ese niño
que todos los profesores queremos tener
en clases ese niño que tiene muchas
ganas de aprender de reflexionar de
adquirir cosas nuevas
pero el barquito está creciendo
pero no levanta la mano igual y se tenía
una voz aguda cierto pero muy penetrante
mis profes y por qué no lo pidieron por
rápido
si vivo profe por eso se morían al tiro
porque se ora mucho pero duermo le dije
yo no sabes cuántos inventos cuántos
descubrimientos en nuestra humanidad se
han hecho a través de la templanza de la
paciencia
si profe pero eso era antes es en la
parte de la prehistoria ahora estamos en
la época de la inmediatez
no sabía qué hacer no tuve cómo
responderle en más tuve que dejarlo
salir 10 minutos antes al recreo pero yo
necesitaba tener una estrategia perfecta
para que ellos pudieran nuevamente
enamorarse de la historia de la
humanidad
y ahí se me ocurrió los invite a hacer
un viaje
con mucho ropa
[Música]
ah
porque al más mínimo ruido al más mínimo
paso en falso nuestra presa se puede
escapar
y habremos perdido días horas semanas
para poder pillar el momento exacto y
tirar nuestra lanza pum y tener nuestro
alimento
niños niñas quiero que cierren sus ojos
se hagan sus ojos
imaginen que estamos en un círculo
grande
lleno de hombres mujeres y niños
todos esperando el momento exacto donde
esa persona al centro del escenario
para con dos piedras pegándole hasta que
llega un una chispa y se produce algo
mágico algo que esas mujeres y esos
hombres están esperando hace mucho
algo llamado fue
se imaginan
la cara de esos hombres y mujeres al
sentir ese calor en su cuerpo por
primera vez después de mucho tiempo
ellos empezaron a sentir algo
internamente algo que les produjo una
sensación maravillosa poder bailar
disfrutar y todo eso se transformó en
una fiesta porque segundos santos
señoras y señores no solamente fue el
juego no fue solamente fue el calor en
sus pies sino que fue también la
posibilidad de cocinar sus alimentos
gracias a ese invento hace
descubrimientos
pudieron cocinar sus alimentos
gracias a eso nosotros podemos estar
entendiendo nos ahora sí porque gracias
a eso
al comer estos alimentos cocidos nuestra
neurona empezaron a multiplicarse tac
tac tac tac
empezamos a entendernos esos
hombres y mujeres con cara de mono que
muchas veces nosotros hemos reído de
ellos esos primitivos gracias a su
prensa a su paciencia aquellos salían
solamente con una lanza precaria y con
mucho ímpetu y ganas de salvar a toda
una comunidad cazaban sus alimentos y en
eso no había un acto maléfico era un
sentido supervivencia gracias a ellos y
descubrieron no solamente el fuego sino
que también el lenguaje
esa misma cara ha nadado críen ustedes
lo tenía en el sexto básico 12 ahí fue
el momento exacto en donde yo puedo
hacer esa pregunta y pude hacer esa
pregunta que le hago a todos los textos
básicos hace más de 20 años
niños y niñas
que sueñan ustedes
con ser cuando grande
y ahí adivinen que levantó la mano
el bar de 2 gordito no solamente el
gordito sino que todos en esa sala niños
y niñas
un maravilloso momento no se preocupen
tengo tiempo para escucharlos a todos ya
todas el gordito profe yo cuando grande
quiero ser youtubers
u2 ver youtube por favor alguien me
puede decir dónde hay quedaron esas
ganas de ser astronautas científicas o
campeonas del mundial de fútbol a ver no
tengo nada contra los youtubers por
favor en mayo también me río mucho con
eso con esos vídeos pero
donde pasamos del descubrimiento del
fuego
así en youtube
en qué momento nos perdimos
en qué momento pasamos eso pasamos a
hacer astronautas científicos
el baile del niño con la mochila al
pollo castillo hola soy germán vuelvo a
repetir no tengo nada contra ellos y
todo bien pero estamos hablando cosas
importantes señoras y señores estamos
hablando por ejemplo de tap
10.000 ac
la agricultura
esos hombres y mujeres descubrieron que
podían posicionarse en un solo lugar
armar hogar terminaron de ser pueblos
nómades a sedentarios
pensaron a trabajar colaborativamente
porque atención millennials
centralizados
usted cree en que él con work coworking
o como se diga en ahora papá pues no el
trabajo colaborativo es de acá 10.000 ac
aún así no sabían responder dije que más
puede ser que más puede ser
hace seis mil siete mil años atrás
hombres y mujeres se agruparon para
traducir un código para poder
entendernos la escritura escritura
maravillosa escritura que ahora se
resume en que en un emoticón
en un emoticón que no es más que un
círculo
perfecto maravillosos círculos
eso es
vamos
a mesopotamia
y mesopotamia una niña soñaba con
transformar un tronco
en algo para transportar a todo un
pueblo
la rueda claro ustedes se quedan ahí
porque la rueda ahora está en todos los
lugares están en cualquier lugar uno va
a un negocio una insignificante rueda
pero imagínense la cara de esas personas
que no podían transportar nada porque
todo era muy pesado
tienes como en la rueda pueden llegar a
otros pueblos pueden empezar a
comercializar otras cosas que en otros
lugares fueron conocidos
las ruedas señoras y señores es algo más
maravilloso que el oro no no que el
petróleo no no no no no
es el invento más guay huacho jay jay de
la historia
todo se pudrió sea
todo se pudrió como lo hago entender
como hago entender
a esos niños la importancia de la
paciencia la templanza del tiempo se
quien nacieron en la época de la
inmediatez cómo puedo cómo puedo
conquistar a esas personitas
si es que ellos no quieren esperar no
tienen paciencia
es más como les puedo explicar que
leonardo da vinci fracaso muchas veces
antes de transformarse en el genio que
todos conocemos
de gordita
tomaste desayuno y día en la mañana
tú eres brillante el maldito eres
maravilloso eduardito no te dan ganas de
no sé de inventar algo nuevo que cambie
el rumbo de esta humanidad no te
gustaría hacer el próximo inventor de la
rueda eduard hito profe es que ya está
todo inventado para que a ver del tiempo
en eso ahora vienen los robots
la inteligencia artificial lo acepto
y el alma
yo pensé que el barítono había escuchado
pues si me escuchó y prosiguió profes a
ver estuvo conversando con mi hermano
mayor que ya influencer
y me dijo que lo que usted nos enseña
es compartir la historia los profes
ustedes como un romántico
con esas palabras me sentí que llegaba
una flecha directo a mi corazón
me sentí como este mamut casado por ese
proyecto
ese niño con esas palabras
me capturó y me va a comentar
me sentí como un mamut como el
rinoceronte cayendo a pedazos
sentí que
qué es el niño a los 12 años tenía mucha
razón
claro porque es un punto para la
tecnología ahora los niños comprenden
todo mucho más rápido es cierto bueno a
veces no es tan bueno
entonces ahí pensé que no se me notará
mucho mi enojo obviamente y le dije a
ver joven
yo yo no soy un romántico
yo soy un profesor con vocación
hasta mañana
ah
profesor
convocación
igual romántico
es
lo mismo
y como no
como no va a ser lo mismo
si tengo que esperar 12 años de mi vida
para ver recién los frutos de mi trabajo
cuando esos hombres y mujeres salgan a
la vida real y pongan en práctica todo
lo que yo le he enseñado
sí
prehistóricos hoy
ya mucha honra porque gracias a esos
prehistóricos nosotros podemos estar acá
comunicándonos
soy romántico como todos aquellos que se
dedican a la docencia que nos interesa
mucho más que esos 42 niños en la sala
más que se saquen una buena nota sepan
dónde poner sus emociones
romántico soy primitivo soy igual que mi
compañeros docentes
que nos levantamos en la mañana muy
temprano para tomar hasta tres micros
para llegar a la escuela pública a
recibir el curso que tenemos de jefatura
y después pasar sala por sala motivando
a los niños y niñas para que puedan
aprender algo sobre la historia y la
humanidad a ver si alguna vez aprendimos
algo de nosotros mismos y después corro
por los pasillos como el pan con manteca
frío que me quedo de la mañana y el
tequila hasta la disímil si para llegar
a la reunión con los apoderados eso
apoderado que me culpan a mí por lo rojo
que tienen sus hijos bueno nunca
llegamos a acuerdos con los apoderados
no pero eso suele suceder en la reunión
de donde hay educación de por medio pero
bueno después ahí no termina
me voy directamente a las clases
particulares que hago por fuera y
después de las tres y particulares corro
al preuniversitario al otro lado a la
ciudad porque porque no me alcanza el
sueldo porque el profesor romántico se
le ocurrió casarse
pero también separarse
y dios mío después terminó esa clase
donde esos alumnos tenían más sueño que
ellos los tenía que motivar pero no
importa porque termina mi jornada
entonces agarró la locomoción pública en
horario punta
y allí me subo entre medio de un agua
tita alguna embarazada al cuchillo más
bonita y el sobaco de un músico
callejero que es muy talentoso pero ha
trabajado todo el día me entienden y ahí
estoy entre la guatita la embarazada y
el sobaco del músico
y me río pues me doy cuenta que me
encanta me pega me fascina mi profesión
me mueve y llego
a mi departamento
es el momento de descansar
llegó me saco mis zapatitos y hay cosas
más ricas
dado cariñito en la alfombra
y miro el peluche de mi hija va a estar
de cumpleaños seis años va a cumplir y
cuando pienso en la carita de ella
cuando reciba el regalo que quería todo
cobra sentido
y me relajo
me relajo hasta que me doy cuenta que no
corregido así un alto de pruebas que
tengo que entregar mañana y es más
porque al profesor romántico no hace
pruebas de alternatiba no hace pruebas
de desarrollo porque quiere hacer
reflexionar a los alumnos
y ahí me doy cuenta que a lo mejor
debería seguir los pasos del guatón
gonzález el guatón gonzález un profesor
que el año pasado renunció a todo y se
fue a vender seguros
yaron recibe buena luz ahora también
tiene tiempo con su familia o mejor aún
a lo mejor que tengo que hacer caso de
partido
y transformarme en un youtube
estaré muy viejo para eso
no lo sé
bueno y cuando ya todo está en calma y
hasta todos perdidos no lo sé saco mi
celular
y empiezo a revisar la notificación es
cierto porque el profesor también tiene
derecho a recibir whatsapp
instagram kinder
también tengo mi necesidad es cierto
y llegó facebook
esto les quiero comentar no le pasa a
usted que están conversando con alguien
algún tema y abren fue una aplicación y
sale lo que ustedes querían escuchar o
ver leer
será que estamos llenos de micrófonos
no lo sé pero mira
la inteligencia artificial wow
mira justo un artículo bueno bueno
obviamente empecé a leer empecé a ver de
dónde venía porque hay que ver de dónde
viene obviamente la fuente pero si era
fidedigna
la inteligencia artificial
no no no
el barrito tengo la respuesta tengo la
respuesta ha perdido ya lo sé no tiene
ya su partido tengo la respuesta de
gordito teórico vuelvo a los alumnos qué
lindo día nos regalan
hoy día vamos a aprender una
palabra nueva
esta palabra se llama en para ti
que viene del griego en parla
qué significa emocionarse
el gordito
quería hablar contigo
la inteligencia artificial que tú tan
tanto idolatras
no es mala puesto no
soy yo el que a lo mejor estoy
rechazando un poco los avances
es que tenía miedo cuartito tenía mucho
miedo tenía miedo que un robot hiciera
una clase mucho más entretenía que la
mía
pero ya no tengo miedo
no tengo nada de miedo porque sé cuál la
diferencia entre los robots que nosotros
los seres humanos que nosotros gordito
los colores sangre por las venas
nos emocionamos del barrido
cuando ustedes salgan de cuarto medio yo
voy a llorar el bendito no voy a llorar
me voy a emocionar porque voy a acordar
de esos chistes que nos tiramos en clase
de 'www esas penas que llegaron a mí
hablar y pedirme consejos por eso me voy
a emocionar
emocionar empatizar ponerse en el lugar
del otro algo que nos hace mucho más
humanos
es gordito
nosotros nos emocionamos aprendemos yo
aprendo de tito aprende de mí y así
aprendemos de toda la humanidad
eduardito
nunca la inteligencia artificial
va a poder sacarnos a nosotros los seres
humanos
profe
ya no quiero ser más youtuber
[Música]
lo que pasa profes que estuvimos
conversando comentando toda la tarde y
la verdad que nos gusta mucho la
tecnología pero queremos queremos ocupar
la base para hacer algo bueno para la
humanidad por ejemplo alguna aplicación
que pueda sacar a la gente de la pobreza
algo que le da herramientas a la gente
para salir adelante como esa herramienta
que usted nos da todos los días
hay todo con sentido todo
en esas palabras de guardo
todo cobró sentido
porque señoras y señores la inteligencia
artificial no nos viene a reemplazar
no le tengan miedo no le tengamos miedo
pero no tengamos miedo a ser románticos
seamos románticos sin miedo
porque saben qué
ni mil máquinas nunca
podrán hacer una flor
[Música]
aunque tenga muy buenas tardes nos vemos
la próxima clase
[Música]
tú
ah